I just remember when I finally called
for help I was in a fetal position in
bed couldn't get out in tears all the
time yeah even though I knew I had to
stop I couldn't yeah I could not stop
Hayden panettier gets candid about her
struggle with addiction and losing
custody of her daughter it was the worst
signing those papers was like
the most heartbreaking thing I've ever
had to do in my life the actress opens
up on red table talk revealing she
suffered from postpartum depression
after the birth of her now
seven-year-old daughter Kaya whom she
shares with her ex Vladimir Klitschko I
feel like people saw me struggling right
A lot it was pretty obvious and
still nobody came and asked questions
back in 2015 Hayden hinted at her battle
with depression during a chat with E.T I
understand the Spectrum now of
postpartum the symptoms don't have to be
as in your face and obvious I definitely
struggled with that a little bit it's
not a good feeling but women need to
know that they're not alone to cope
Hayden says she leaned on alcohol I did
what I had seen family and the people
around me do whenever they were
depressed or stressed out or anything
which was reach for a bottle which made
it that much worse the Nashville star
reveals she entered her first of several
treatment facilities for substance abuse
when Kyle was four months old I like had
had it with myself and explains that at
the time art was imitating life her
character on Nashville faced addiction
and postpartum depression do you want to
have so much pride as a mom and as soon
as somebody says something that
questions even puts your mothering
skills into question I mean mama bear
comes out it is a rough topic I had to
go to work every day and be acting out
what I was truly going through so by the
time I got home I didn't want to sit
there with my own feelings and work them
out well you know I just want to escape
and after Nashville wrapped in 2018 she
says she hit rock bottom I was leaning
on that bottle during that time off and
it was bad I was stuck in this
horrifying nightmare that just wouldn't
end and completely by myself and that is
it was scary it was it was terrifying
and I knew I was ruining my health I
turned jaundice at one point like yellow
eyes and went to a doctor and they said
if you don't stop right now you're
heading towards a liver that's not gonna
heal itself anymore yeah and I looked up
liver transplants and it says they give
you only like five years I made her
issues with substance abuse hating
relinquished custody of her then almost
three-year-old daughter who lives in
Ukraine with her dad a quote very
upsetting decision she claims wasn't up
for discussion I was gonna go work on
myself right and I was gonna get better
and when I got better
then things could change and she could
come to me and I could have my time with
her but that
um that didn't happen I thought she was
going over to visit him like she always
did and then once she was over there
which it was immediately I want full
custody of her which was a shock to me
ultimately he didn't sign the papers
giving Vladimir full custody I knew the
most unselfish thing that I could do was
to make that hard decision and just try
to work on myself now she says she hopes
one day to regain custody adding that
being open about the heartbreaking
experience has been cathartic I've never
been this honest brutally honest about
myself or my personal life but and make
it made me depressed trying to hide my
myself there's just something very
freeing about just being yourself
[Music]
foreign